I want to say this to anyone who's
listening if there's anything you listen
to all the stuff that I described that
was really tough that I went through was
not as hard as me quitting my job by far
the hardest decision of my entire life
Bar None because the things that I was
actually caught up with were the
opinions of other people opinions of my
father and the opinions of the people
that I went to school with who I thought
would judge me for leaving this good job
to probably become a failed gym owner
and how lame that would sound compared
to consultant going to Harvard and blah
like I was going to go from Peak white
collar to
a very blue color you know profession
making significantly less because I
quote loved it and I'll say this again
but like sometimes you have to let other
people's dreams for your life die for
yours to live and for me it was like
when I continued to every day not want
to wake up that was my wake-up call it
was the hardest decision in my entire
life by far